hey leute was geht ab und herz bekommen
bei einem neuen video
heute geht es ganz einfach mal um die
unterschiede zwischen jungen und mädchen
auf facebook im realen leben verhalten
sich jungen und mädchen unterschiedlich
und diese maschinen fallen zweiten
treten dann logischerweise auf facebook
aus und über diese breuckmann mit euch
reden
ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht so ganz
genau womit ich jetzt überhaupt anfangen
soll weil mir fällt echt ziemlich viel
zu diesem thema ein
aber fangen wir einfach mal in folgenden
punkten erstens bilder kommentieren
bei jungen läuft das ganze eigentlich
ziemlich einfach ab irgendwie hat sein
profilbild geändert neues foto
hinzugefügt was weiß ich geb dir so
viele verschiedene sachen und in koppl
kommentiert ein einfach geiles bild dk
keine ahnung und zurück kommt ganz so
bald danke
bei mädchen sieht das ganze aber ein
ganz kleines bisschen mehr anders aus
ein mädchen kommentiert das bild von
einem anderen mädchen beispielsweise so
wie du bist voll hübsch und so und dann
kommt zurück
ja danke aber guck dich mal an du bist
so viel hübscher dann kommt auf der
anderen seite wieder zurück nein stimmt
doch gar nicht auf der anderen seite
geht es wieder weiter doch du bist die
rückflüsse und so geht das einfach immer
weiter manchmal ist das doch recht so
ganz kleines bisschen übertrieben oder
seid mal ehrlich so und jetzt gehts
weiter mit punkt zwei bilder an sich
wenn jungs ein neues bild machen
dann sieht das ungefähr so aus wir jungs
stehen einfach so vom spiegel machen
somit handy gegen ein foto oder keine
ahnung sitzen herum machen foto und
fertig na klar gibt es auch so 5% von
süchtigen harte kost ragni somit tank
top cap kette keine ahnung so in dosen
sitzen
und dann kommen jetzt wieder zu dem
mädchen und da sieht das ganze natürlich
wieder ein bisschen anders aus bis das
perfekte foto entsteht wo so make-up
gesichtsausdruck alles passt muss man
natürlich erstmal ein paar hundert fotos
machen ist ja selbstverständlich
und die location ist natürlich
irgendwann
maisfeld erste feld einfach irgend so
ein feld ich meine liste einfach mal so
alles voll mit getreide und mittendrin
steht da einfach mal so ein mädchen
aber was ich dazu noch sagen muss die
bilder sehen manchmal echt gut aus
ehrlich so wie jetzt ihr kennt doch
bestimmt alle diese mega lang texte die
irgendein mädchen beim anderen mädchen
auf die pin man schreibt so von wegen so
beste freundin blabla keine ahnung und
ich verstehe nicht nochmal sie einfach
per privatnachricht schreibt muss ja
nicht gleich jeder ist und als letztes
jetzt auch was was auf jeden fall für
die mädchen spricht es freut mich
ehrlich dass ihr nicht so wie manche
komischen jungs seid die mir einfach den
ganzen tag eben solche lästigen spielern
fallgeschichten danke so am ende muss
ich jetzt vielleicht noch etwas sagen
und das ganze mehr so speziell an die
mädchen auch wenn es manchmal jetzt
nicht ganz so rüberkam
ich finde das ganze natürlich vollkommen
okay was ihr da so macht also ich
akzeptiere es ehrlich meinen hobbys zum
beispiel jetzt fußballspiele neuer
hobbys fotos machen oder so deswegen
versteht das ganze jetzt nicht falsch
das weißt du einfach mal so ne da so ein
vergleich zwischen jungen menschen auf
facebook so wird das wasser doch leider
schon wieder mit diesem video
ich hoffe es hat euch natürlich gefallen
und ich würde euch mal bitten falls ihr
euch irgendwie mit dem video
identifizieren könnte dann hast du
einfach mal ein daumen nach oben da und
schreibt doch bitte mal unten in die
kommentare
also alle die jetzt gerade das video
geschaut haben ob ihr ein junge oder ein
mädchen sein das würde ich gern mal
wissen
und ja hier unten rechts kommt ihr noch
mal zu meinem letzten video dort ging es
darum die fünf dinge die jeder kennt und
hier unten links zu meinem vorletzten
video dass wir einen fragen und
antworten video das nennt sich streaming
ads in drei minuten so viele fragen
möglich beantworten
ja ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr alles
abdeckt und so lassen aber hier oben da
und wir sehen uns dann würde ich mal
sagen nächste woche irgendwann beim
nächsten video